President Trump called this a war and it
is exactly that, so let's act like it.
Michigan Governor Gretchen Whitmer
compares today's fight against COVID-19
to the war against Nazi Germany and she's prepared to use emergency powers in the path to victory.
Tyranny has a new name and it's called a pandemic. Robert Wiese is a constitutional lawyer
with the Conservative American Freedom Law Center and a co-plaintiff in a lawsuit
the center has filed against Governor Whitmer. Quarantine is when you restrict the liberty of people
who are sick, and tyranny is when you restrict the liberty of people who are healthy.
Wiese alleges that Whitmer has violated the First Amendment by banning church services,
the Second Amendment by closing gun stores,
and the Fourteenth Amendments Equal
Protection Clause by seeming to
arbitrarily allow some places to stay
open while banning others one of the
clients from Saginaw Michigan she could
travel from her home in Saginaw to go to
shall avoid and go to a pet store and
buy goldfish she could go to a
convenience store buy a lotto ticket she
could go to a liquor store buy liquor
she could purchase marijuana but if she
went to her actual property in shall
avoid County it was a criminal
misdemeanor
she had a restriction where you could
you know be on a lake in a boat without
a motor but you couldn't be in the lake
with a boat with a motor and then she
places restriction you go to Home Depot
and you can buy lumber but you couldn't
buy flooring you couldn't buy flowers
and you couldn't buy wallpaper I
represent a landscaper the landscaping
businesses weren't permitted white
landscaping but there's virtually no
contact with clients the landscapers can
show up with somebody's property they
can mow their lawn talk about social
distancing they can exercise it tenfold
never have any contact with a client
they can send him a bill and so forth
and he was losing thousands and
thousands of dollars a day the American
freedom Law Center has also filed a
First Amendment lawsuit against New York
Mayor Bill DeBlasio who has banned
protests but permits walking and jogging
it's a total ban on First Amendment
activity which requires the highest
level of scrutiny to apply so I think
you know if they want to go that drastic
route because they said there's no
exceptions they're gonna they're gonna
have a higher burden to demonstrate the
the justification for those types of
restrictions so to all the people that
have disagreed with the actions that
I've taken or feel their rights are
being infringed I want to say this
we are taking a limited action for a
limited amount of time to save people's
lives people who favor the lockdowns
would say are you really willing to
trade more deaths for kind of defending
a rather abstract principle or as they
would put it your particular conception
of freedom these liberties might seem
extravagant to some but they are the
fundamental principles that were put in
place by our founding fathers America
has become the epicenter of the pandemic
the death toll doubled in just two days
in America's top infectious disease
specialists is now warning that millions
of people face infection more than half
of the American public will get
coronavirus and if the data that they
model out is accurate we could lose more
than a million Americans to the virus
that's 2.2 million people would have
died if we did nothing we just carried
on our life constitutional law professor
Josh Blackman says that while the
emergency orders may have been legal
early on that they can become less
constitutional as new information about
the threat level and their effectiveness
becomes clear if the elected branches
say there's some crisis that's going on
the courts are hasn't the second-guess
that but I think that deference only
lasts for so long a lot of the measures
that might have seen necessary and
proper months ago now seem perhaps
overkill Blackmun points to a recent
Texas Supreme Court opinion finding that
as the threat lessens the continued
burdens on constitutional liberties may
not survive judicial scrutiny a federal
ruling out of Kentucky struck down that
state's non-essential designation of
drive-in church services and seriously
questioned the constitutionality of
government making such designations at
all I don't think the government can
decide what is and is not essential with
any sort of objective measure now for a
lot of activities
I think deference is probably the name
of the game but we get to things like
religion exercise and the right to bear
arms
this definition of essential becomes a
lot more a heart to justify the desire
to take these steps to prevent the
transmission of the disease are
unprecedented we even saw checkpoints my
own home state of Texas put up a
checkpoint at SLU easy Ana border you
know we have Texas Rangers at
the airport giving people forum saying
you have to be warranting and actually
house tolls make sure people are staying
home I just didn't think this was
possible just it's stunning how quickly
the government has interjected itself
governor Whitmer has analogized the
current situation to world war ii to
justify the lockdown orders in world war
ii there weren't people lining up at the
capitol to protest the fact that they
had to drop everything they were doing
and build planes or tanks they rolled up
their sleeves and they got to work we
were all in this together
Blackman's points out that in this
period the US government did order
curfews for Japanese American citizens
and eventually sent some in to
internment camps now we don't talk about
those cases because they're considered
really bad but the Supreme Court upheld
the curfew had to be saying that there's
risks of sabotage risk the Espionage
that maybe these Japanese people are
didn't league with our warring power and
that this was an appropriate measure the
court more or less not approved of the
attention but they approved of the
curfew measure could this potentially
set precedence beyond a pandemic type
situation there's an old maxim I think
it's from Cicero and it's translated as
during the times of war the loss falls
silent I will amend Cicero's adage
during times of epidemic and the loss
fall silent I think the Supreme Court
will stay of us as long as possible but
they may have to be called to intervene
you know what happens if there's a
election coming up in November and there
are some corona related issues involving
mail-in ballots and people waiting
online and social distancing at the
polling booths and they will set
precedence and I think they will
probably bad precedent because whatever
courts decide cases under crunch time
conditions without enough time to
consider things that rules we create
lousy so far governor's in Wisconsin and
Oregon have had their executive orders
nullified by state and county courts who
ruled that they weren't properly
reauthorized by the legislature and
wheezes challenge to the Michigan order
is pending in federal court as is his
First Amendment challenge to New York's
order meanwhile some businesses continue
to open despite lockdown orders local
sheriff's increasingly refuse
to enforce closures DA's refused to
prosecute and mobility data shows
Americans increasingly moving through
the world again as they make their own
individual risk assessments now civil
disobedience has been one way that we
actually made a lot of policy changes in
the United States it's not our burden to
prove our freedom is their burden to
prove that the restriction on our
Liberty meets the constitutional state